how's it going Bryce this is pure pie
I'm gonna go through catacombs that's
fine all right Jesus once I
what was I Oh Jase is right environment
it
Oh
this controversy that's a chick
I would kiss it but it's kind of nice Oh
God
hello
what that [ __ ]
don't LA
Oh Dan supposed to drive out here oh oh
no no I'm sorry but it's not my
right
Jesus guys Jesus guys what the [ __ ]
attacks all [ __ ] in a duck alright
people Daria you never know alright
get this get this no problem oh my god
oh this is stuff oh god no is this a
stuff
it's really tiny here and it is hello
okay
Oh
okay okay
you're mean really mean okay
it's not funny stuff way okay I don't
like you I'm sorry okay
all right play the music
find the crying koltes i've got damn it
I don't like what
oh Jesus
okay this is weird that's okay do you
have something for me
it's gonna be okay I like you
I didn't I didn't take anything hey [ __ ]
alright just gonna go this has been
great this way I appreciate it
seriously okay alright I got all my keys
I got the right one I got the blue one
and I got the green one did not come
this far Oh God
what's all this everything is fine and
just gonna say alright here we go
we found it yes sweet three keys three
holes oh my god okay let's see there we
go alright you go there you go there
it's better be something good in here
alright
yeah what if we can
No
just give it give it ah
thank you thank you thank you phone sir
yeah fast oh ah awesome system all the
power to be done you to be on evening
yes that's my clue no breakfast for the
world
yes will see my face oh I just got it hi
I found this awesome camera and its
really [ __ ] we this is really scary
this is like our last oh my god circle
all but sauce freaking back to your
breast okay okay
Jesus Christ are you serious oh my god
no no hello
I'm not a big fan of this
oh oh oh oh my god that was insane I
wanna just get
I never want this fast before
okay we did it I'm the best let's never
go here again I think there's no better
places just a few oh my god
all right bros that was the catacomb
challenge we did it we made it out alive
I can't believe it
it was so [ __ ] scary I remember when
I walked down in the beginning my heart
was beating so fast it was just
incredible is it always this dark do I
have any one but even though it was
horrible and horrifying it was still a
very very funny and awesome unique
experience so if you like this please
show your support in the comments and
leave a like I really appreciate it
and hopefully if you bros enjoyed it we
can do more stuff like this with other
stuff so thank you both for your support
as always the film as above so below
comes out later this month
definitely thank you both to check it
out and that's all for me for now brass
as always stay awesome bro fears can you
read that according to mythology that's
inscription over the gates of Hell
police we made from their beliefs and
synced with diamonds
Sheila